Transcriber: Elif Usta
Gözden geçirme: esra kurul
Merhaba.
Günaydın.
Bugün sabah buraya geldiğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.
Ben Yoshinori Moriwaki.
1990′da Japonya’dan Türkiye’ye geldim.
Hangi rüzgar beni Türkiye’ye getirdi?
Dolmabahçe Sarayı’nın arka tarafında
Swiss Otel var.
Japonya’nın.
Bina sahibi olarak Japonya’nın.
Bankacı, sigortacı ve bizim şirket de
dahil bina sahibi olarak...
1988′de inşa edilmeye başladı ve
1991′de bitmek üzereyken
ben 26 Aralık 1990′da
aslında bir aylığına Türkiye’ye
binanın teslimi ve kontrol amaçlı geldim.
Ama gelir gelmez
üçüncü bina kontrolü
yani sorumlusu sen ol diye
proje müdürü bana söyledi.
Dolayısıyla bir ay değil, bir sene burada
olmam lazım diye başladı, bir sene yaptım.
Sonra Çerkezköy’de YKK diye
Japonya’nın fermuar fabrikası var,
evet, o fabrikayı yaptık.
Sonra Gebze’de Honda fabrikasını,
Adapazarı’nda Toyota fabrikasını,
Antalya’daki Akdeniz Üniversite’sinin
Organ Nakli Hastanesi’ni,
meteoroloji projesi,
Balıkesir, Zonguldak, Çatalca,
böyle projeler yaptık ve
şimdi 32 sene geçti.
Türkiye’de
yıldız kayarken
hayal kurarsan gerçekleşir diye
bir şey var, değil mi?
Japonya’da da aynı.
Bizde de bu var.
Önce bunu bir kenara koyuyorum.
Ben küçükken, yani küçük derken
Japonya’da ilkokulu bitirirken
büyüyünce ne yapacağım diye
en son ilkokulu bitirirken
yazı yazacaktım.
Orada ben yurtdışına gideceğim ama
tabii ki daha ne iş yapacağım belli değil,
ama yurtdışına gitmek istiyorum.
O anda babamın işi,
Türkiye’de nasıl söyleniyor TED gibi
elektrik üretiliyor, enerji üretiliyor.
Ben dünya için enerji
üreteceğim diye yazdım.
Sonra ortaokula gittim.
Japonya’da ortaokulda
bayanlar yemek pişiriyor
ve kumaşla bir şeyler yapıyorlardı.
Erkekler ise tahta kesiyor,
kitaplık yapıyor veya dolap gibi
küçük kutu gibi bir şey yapıyor.
Ve proje, basit bir proje
civata somun ve böyle bir şeyin
mekanizması ile projeyi yazıyor.
Yazdım ve ilk defa öğretmene getirince
“Aa, bu benim işim!”
diye hissettim kendi kendime.
Tabii o anda mimar mı, inşaat mühendisi mi
yoksa makinacı mı bilmiyordum.
Ama babamın elektrik işini ben göremediğim
için yok elektrik değil diye düşündüm.
Sonra araştırdım,
tabii şimdi cep telefonundan
siz kolayca araştırabilirsiniz.
Ama ben küçükken, bunlar yoktu.
Sözlük, çok büyük sözlük.
Bir dolapta tamamen sözlük vardı.
Onlara tek tek bakıp araştırdım ve sonunda
mimar olmak istiyorum diye düşündüm.
Ve mimar olmak ve yurtdışında
çalışmak için neler yapmak lazım.
Araştırdım, araştırdım ve sonra
büyük bir tahtaya yani vücudumuz kadar
büyük bir tahtaya yazdım.
Neler yapmak lazım diye yazdım.
Tabii ara ara değiştiriyordum.
Ama bunu odadaki duvara yapıştırdım ve
uyurken yatağın üstünde de oluyordu.
Ve tuvalette kapının arkasındaydı,
tuvalette oturup böyle bakıyordum.
Yani her zaman bakıyordum.
Kendim hayal kurmak için.
Yurtdışında mimar olmak için
ne yapmak lazım diye yazıp
her zaman bunu düşünüyordum.
Tamam.
Ondan sonra.
Şimdi bu yıldız kayma olayına dönüyorum.
Normalde insan yıldız
kaymaya başladığında:
“Ahh, yıldız kaymaya başladı,
ben ne söyleyeceğim?”
O zaman, artık yıldız gidiyor, değil mi?
O anda düşünüyorsa
çoğu insan yıldız kaymaya başladığında
hayalini söylemiyor.
Söylemiyorsa, tabii ki gerçekleşmiyor.
Ama mesela ben kendime;
yurtdışına gitmek istiyorum,
mimar olmak istiyorum.
Hemen yıldız kaymaya başladığında
yurtdışında mimar diyebilirim.
Ve zaten kendi kendine her zaman
öyle düşünüyorsa
insanda güç var.
İnsan düşünebildiği bir konuysa,
mutlaka yapabilir ve gerçekleştirebilir
ne kadar zor olsa da.
Tabii ki zaman da lazım,
ben de sonuna kadar geldim.
Ben şimdi yaş olarak biraz genç
gösterebilirim ama ben 67 yaşındayım.
60′a kadar bir çizgi,
Japonya’da bir çizgi var.
O çizgiye kadar ben bunu
gerçekleştirdim diye söyleyebilirim.
Tabii Japonya’dan Türkiye’ye geldim
ve ne yurtdışı
tabii arada Bulgaristan’a gittim,
Tayland’ın yanındaki Laos’a gittim.
Biraz kısa kısa var ama sonuç olarak
çoğunlukla Türkiye’deyim.
Şimdi Türkiye’de tabi sadece
kendi şirketimin değil,
Japonya yurtdışı inşaat şirketleri
derneğinin de
Türkiye genel sekreterliğini yaptığım için
Osmangazi için de ve Marmaray’dayken de
tabii Japonya grubu olarak, aynı Japon
grup ama başka şirkette ama
derneğin Türkiye genel sekreteri olarak
ara ara gidiyordum ve denetliyordum.
Ve Mecidiyeköy’deki viyadük,
E5′in üstünde var orası,
özellikle mevcut kolonu kesip
sismik izalatör,
şimdi depremden sonra siz de
sismik izalatör diye bir kelime duydunuz,
yani depreme karşı iyi çalışıyor ve
yukarıda sıkıntı olmayacak.
Yani malın içini 7.5 deprem olsa da
sıkıntı yok gibi güçlendirme yaptık.
Birinci köprü, ikinci köprü de dahil.
Ve böyle mega bir proje de yaptık.
Ve her sene Türkiye - Japonya
yurtdışı inşaat şirketleri olarak
toplantı da yapıyoruz.
Covid’den dolayı iki - üç sene yapamadık,
bu sene inşallah yapacağız.
Yani böyle ben kendi hayallerimi
gerçekleştiriyorum.
Şimdi ben 60 yaşından sonra
yani eskiden ben de spor yapardım.
Kışın yerde karın çok olduğu
bir yerde yaşadığım için
buz pateni, kayak çok iyi yapıyorum.
Ama sonra fazla müzik yapmadım,
benim ofisimin yanında müzik çalar var
orada baktım çocuklar
ben de kemana başladım 60′tan sonra.
Piyanoya başladım, Japon davuluna başladım
ve spor olarak da tüplü dalışa başladım.
Tüplü dalış özellikle
Gölcük Değirmendere’de
Deniz kenarı dolgu yapılmış,
200 metre ve 2 kilometre,
tam iyi yapılmadığı için
30 metre aşağı kaydı.
Ve orası hala şimdi 20 küsur sene geçti,
orada enkazı var.
Ben onu kendi gözlerimle görmek istedim,
onun için 65 yaşımda
tüplü dalışa başladım.
Şimdi 3 yıl oldu, 40 metre kadar aşağı
inip onu kontrol edebilirim.
Ve şimdi Hatay’ı, bir ay iki ay sonra
başka bir hoca ile beraber gidebilirim.
Şimdi o fay hattı, Hatay’a kadar kırıldı.
Hatay’dan sonra denizin içinde
Kıbrıs’a kadar gidebilir.
Yani orayı kontrol etmek de istiyorum.
Japonya ve Türkiye’nin
dostluğunu siz sorarsanız:
Nereye gitmek istersin dünyada?
Çoğu insan Japonya’dan sizin ülkeye
gelmek istiyorum diye söylüyordu.
Siz nasıl?
Ben de, yani siz Türkiye insanları,
Japon insanlarını çok seviyorum diyor.
Japon insanı da seviyor.
Bunun kültürü dostluk nereden başladı?
Geçen sabah sinemada vardı.
Aslında o yönetmen arkadaş aynı memlekette
ve onun oyunununda ben de çalıştım biraz.
Ondan sonra bunu 1890′da
Ertuğrul gemisini getirip Japonya
İmparatoru’na hediye etti.
Ve sonra dönüyorken maalesef
Japonya’nın sonbaharında fırtınadan battı.
200′e yakın kişiyi kaybettik ama
69 kişi kurtulabildi.
Ve ona Japonya’da bir adadaki insan
çok iyi baktı,
ve sonra Türkiye’ye geri verdi.
Bunu Japon insanları unuttu ama
Türk insanları unutmadı.
1985′te Tahran’da
İran - Irak savaşı başladı.
Saddam Hüseyin 48 saat sonra
hangi uçak uçarsa atak yapacağız
diye konuştu.
Her ülkeden insanlar kaçmaya çalıştı
ama Japonya’da bir sıkıntı oldu.
Uçak uçamıyordu.
O anda, o zamanki Başbakan Turgut Özal
bizim için,
mahsur kalmış 215 Japon insanı için
sizin uçağınızı Japonya için verdi.
Orhan kaptan dahil
başka hostes arkadaşlar,
ara ara ben de onlarla görüşüyorum
konuşuyoruz,
Orhan kaptanı maalesef 2013′te kaybettik
ama her zaman görüşüyorum.
Ve o anda Japonlar;
neden Türkiye uçağını bize verdi?
Çünkü 215 kişi Türkiye insanına
uçak verilmedi,
o nedenle kamyonla döndüler.
1890′da Ertuğrul gemisi bunun için,
teşekkür ederim anlamında bize yaptı.
Bunu sonra biz Japonlar da anladık.
Bunun için ben bir Japon olarak,
siz Türk insanlarına teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)
Evet böyle dostluk başladı,
şimdi ana olarak deprem.
Siz depremden sonra televizyonda gördünüz.
2011 yılında büyük depremden sonra
Türkiye’deki 81 ilin 64′ünde
ben gidip 452′den fazla seminer verdim.
Dün de Bursa’ya geldim ve
gittiğim yerde seminer yaptım.
Ee tamam çocuklar, Türkiye’de bakıyorum da
deprem için fazla eğitim yapılmıyor.
Ve küçük çocuklar için “Çocuklar Duymasın”
diye bir dizi vardı,
onun gibi deprem için “çocuklar görmesin”.
Yani tabii ki biz Japonya’da da
depremin o kötü durumunu göstermiyoruz.
Biz çocuklar için ne yapıyoruz?
Çizgi film gösteriyoruz.
1999 depreminde Deprem Dede diye,
rahmetli oldu, Işıkara hoca vardı.
Onun çizgi filmi var, siz de biliyorsunuz.
Önce onu gösteriyor, sonra duruyor
ve ben biraz anlatıyorum.
Nasıl bakın? 3 yaşında 5 yaşında
çocuklar nasıl bana bakıyor?
Bugün böyle size
anlattığım gibi konuşursam,
tabii çocuklar iki dakikada
oynamaya başlıyor.
Ama çizgi film ve onlar ile
beraber oyun oynayınca
Tamam 3 kişi gel, beraber kaçarız diye
oyun yapıyoruz.
Öyle yapınca ilkokula giderken de
deprem için dünya için başlarına gelince
“Hmm, bu Japon amcanın
söylediği bu demek.”
Böyle iyi anlayacak.
Tabii sadece ben değil,
başka hoca için de aynı.
Bu tablo bir ülkede
ne kadar deprem meydana geliyor,
5.5 orta seviyedeki deprem,
onu gösteriyor.
Türkiye’de metrekareden bakınca
Japonya dünyada altıncı,
Türkiye on yedinci.
En büyük deprem için söylersek
büyüklük olarak 7.9 Erzincan depremi.
Japonya’da ise 2011′deki Tohoku
yani Fukişima depremi.
Ama maalesef bunu söylemek lazım.
Depremde ölü sayısına bakınca
Türkiye aniden dünyada üçüncü oluyor.
Ve bu sefer Kahramanmaraş ve Hatay
depremini de dahil edersek
birinci de olabilir.
Yani bu ne söylüyor?
Türkiye deprem ülkesi.
Ama sayısal olarak hiç o kadar değil
ve büyüklük de çok değil.
Ona rağmen depremden dolayı
insanlarını kaybediyor.
Onun için bunu ben her yere gidip
bunu özellikle inşaat
mimarisi ile paylaşıyorum.
Ve bunu iyileştirmek çözmek lazım.
Siz artık depremden sonra çok gördünüz,
Türkiye’de 81 ilin 55′i birinci seviyede
tehlikeli ama ikinci üçüncü var.
Eskiden 93 tehlikeli bölge diye
söyleniyordu
ama artık başka hocalar ile
beraber söylüyoruz:
Türkiye yüzde yüz tehlikeli bölge.
Japonya’da da aynı.
Yani biz nereye gidersek gidelim tehlikeli
onun için kaçmak... kaçmamak lazım.
O yerde çözmek lazım.
Ve sıkıntı, 18 milyon yapı stoğu varsa
yani bina varsa maalesef %50′si kaçak.
Yani izinsiz.
Böyle bir sıkıntı var.
Japonya’da izinsiz yok.
Yani ilkokuldaki çocuklar tuvalete gitmek
isterken “Hocam gidebilir miyim?” diyor.
Mutlaka izin alıyor.
Yani Türkiye’deki insanların da,
şirketlerin de, mühendislerin de
bu izni mutlaka alması lazım.
Bunu çözmek lazım diye söylüyorum.
Evet, yaşam üçgeni.
Çok hızlı söyleyeceğim.
Bu sefer Kahramanmaraş depremi de
99 depremi de geceydi.
Yataktan “Ahh, deprem!” diye kalktılar.
Ama çok salladığı için
üçgen halinde saklandığı gibi öldü.
Ve kurtarma ekipleri bu üçgenden
çok kişiyi kurtarabilirdi ama
ama üçgende tabii ki mutlaka
düdük, su ve maske olmalı.
Maske çünkü çok toz oluyor, maske yoksa
bez yani çarşaf veya kazak da olabilir.
Benim 60′dan sonraki yeni hedefim;
Japonya gibi, Türkiye’deki insanlar
söylüyor Japonya’daki binalar çökmüyor,
onun gibi Türkiye’de de yıkılmaz binalar
ve insanları koruyan binalar.
Japonya’da deprem olunca dışarıdaysak
binanın içine kaçıyoruz biz.
Çünkü bina insanı korumak için var.
Böyle olması lazım.
Ben en son Türkiye’de, tabii ben
30 sene daha yaşar mıyım bilmiyorum
ama Japonya’da ortalama 100 yaş
onun için 100 yaşıma kadar yaşayabilirsem
onu yapmaya çalışacağım.
Ve en son çok sayıda insan
biz Türkiye gibi
çökmeyen binalar
yapmaya çalışacağım diye Kolombiya’daki
bir insan söyleyinceye kadar
Türkiye’deki binaları sağlam yapmaya
çalışmak istiyorum.
Bu benim büyük hedefim.
En son olarak, böyle olunca
“Ne Mutlu Türkiye’deyim Diyene!”
(Alkışlar)
Evet, sonuna kadar dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim.